So, to do this even risk assessment,
we said we needed to know two things.
One is, we need these loss functions.
We need these costs, right?
Somebody has to tell me,
because I can't know that, it's not
defined intrinsically in the data.
It's the cost of, you know,
either societal cost,
economic cost, you know, whatever.
As I said before, the cost of
somebody calling somebody stupid,
who's really smart and
large might be much
worse than the cost of calling somebody
smart whose actually stupid and large.
Think about that one, okay?
The, but the basic idea is that
the cost come from outside the data.
But the other thing that I need is that
I actually need to know the probability
that something really is
a four given some measurement.
The probability that really is
a nine given some measurement.
All right?
And we need to be able
to evaluate those.
The way we did that,
if you recall, is that we, we talked
about estimating the likelihood.
That's the probability of
the measurement given that it's,
here we were doing skin colors.
Given that it's a four or nine, or
given that it's skin or not skin.
And then, how did we go from likelihoods
to actual probabilities posteriors?
Well, remember we used Bayes rule.
Okay, and Bayes rule would allow us
to take these likelihood, right?
The probability of getting the
measurement given the class, skin, etc.
Multiply that by this prior,
just what's the probability
of getting a four or nine?
Or, in this case,
of getting a pixel being skin.
Or getting a pixel not being skin.
And you multiply them, and
you have to normalize them.
And you get this posterior,
which was the thing you wanted, okay?
And that's what this
equation down here says.
The probability of skin, given x,
proportional to P of x, given skin,
the likelihood times the prior.
And of course, then, the question came
up of, where does that prior come from?
And again, we had to learn it
somehow from training data.
So we showed an example.
This is from Garrett Bradsky
of classifying skin color.
At the end of the day,
you would basically take this value and
you would compare it to some threshold.
And you'd say okay,
if it's higher than the threshold,
I'm going to call it skin,
otherwise it's not.